Платіжки за газ і електрику в новому опалювальному сезоні не мали б здивувати українців принаймні до кінця зими.
Однак тепло, схоже, буде не скрізь. А радіти помірним цінами за електроенергію теж не варто.
DW з'ясовувала, до чого готуватися в платіжках.
Цінове ралі на блакитне паливо у Європі не повинне лякати українців, тому що в країні діє правило річного газового тарифу,
згідно з яким, незалежно від скачків цін на ринку, українці будуть платити одну ціну за газ до кінця квітня 2022 року.
Водночас ця ціна може відрізнятися навіть для мешканців одного багатоквартирного будинку -
залежно від того, з якою компанією-постачальником укладений контракт.
У майже половини постачальників, які обслуговують 70-80 відсотків українців, ціни нижчі 8 гривень за кубометр.
Утім, якщо населення принаймні знає, за якою ціною купуватиме газ узимку, то для підприємств і держустанов
на кшталт лікарень, шкіл і дитячих садків ця ціна залежить від ринку, а там ціни вже перевалили за 30 гривень за кубометр.
Аналітик Юрій Ніколов відстежує тендери держпідприємств на порталі Прозорро
і каже, що помітив паніку з газом у регіонах ще на початку вересня.
За його спостереженнями, постачальники, які підписали з місцевими органами влади
річні контракти на поставку газу до кінця жовтня, масово розривають контракти.
Адже не бажають постачати газ за ціною у п'ять разів нижчою за ринкову.
Українець в будь-якому куточку України вже найближчим часом буде мати таку ситуацію:
він буде приходити в будь-яку бюджетну установу - лікарні, школи, загс, мерії і буде стикатися з тим,
що там холодні батареї, тому що старі контракти не діють, оскільки ніхто не хоче продавати газ по 7, коли він вже по 35.
І на цих холодних батареях будуть проводитися тендерні процедури, вони довгі
для цієї екстремальної ситуації, тому вони мають бути за скороченою процедурою.
Але законним шляхом це можна зробити, тільки якщо центральна влада відірве дупу від стільця і прийме купу нормативних актів.
У найгіршому випадку місцева влада буде змушена, наприклад,
відправити школи і дитячі садки на карантин, якщо температура приміщень стане критичною.
Зміну ринкової ціни на газ українці теоретично могли б побачити у платіжках за тепло.
Місцеві теплокомуненерго,  які гріють батареї українців на своїх котельнях, купують газ дорого, як звичайне підприємство.
Частково врятувати українців від холодних батарей в лікарнях і високих цін у платіжках за тепло
мав би  меморандум між Асоціацією міст з одного боку та Офісом президента, Кабінетом міністрів і Нафтогазом – з іншого.
Місцева влада пообіцяла не підвищувати тарифи на тепло для населення до кінця опалювального сезону.
Натомість громади отримають з держбюджету щонайменше 11 млрд грн, а Нафтогаз повинен списати з підприємств ТКЕ 30 млрд грн боргу за газ.
Але експерти з енергетики, з якими спілкувалася DW, кажуть, що ця домовленість вирішує проблему лише ситуативно.
Варто спонукати місцеву владу переходити на альтернативні джерела опалення і утеплювати будинки, аби уникнути втрати енергії.
Але разом з тим є приклади вдалі, де місто переводить свої об'єкти на місцеві види палива -
на дерево, на дерев'яну тріску, на палети, і утепляє і я наводжу, власне, приклад Тростянця,
де лікарня, котра була утеплена і переведена на місцеві види палива, має порівняно з іншою лікарнею  такою самою в іншому райцентрі
запланований кошторис витрат на опалення у сім разів менше, ніж такий самий об'єкт, котрий споживає газ, неутеплений.
Скільки платитимуть українці за світло - чутлива тема.
До жовтня 2021 року в платіжках за електроенергію українці отримували єдиний тариф - 1,68 гривень за квт-год.
Але скасування пільгових 90 копійок за перші 100 кВт-год викликало чимало критики.
Тож Кабмін з ініціативи РНБО придумав інакшу схему.
Ті, хто споживає менше 250 квт-год на місяць  куплятимуть електрику по 1,44 грн за кВт-год.
За розрахунками Міністерства енергетики, за такою ціною платитимуть майже 80 відсотків українців.
Решта - 1,68 гривні.
Така цінова політика, щоправда, суперечить дефіциту коштів на енергоринку,
з чим погоджується голова комітету Верховної Ради з питань енергетики та житлово-комунальних послуг.
Ця ціна субсидована, треба чесно говорити.
Якщо рахувати економічно обґрунтовано або базуватися на ринковій ціні, то вона була би вищою.
Вона була б така, як для підприємств. А для підприємств ця ціна зараз більш ніж два рази вища.
Сьогодні підприємства сплачують за електрику приблизно 2,80 грн за кВт-годину.
Ціна залежить від постачальника, типу самого підприємства і класу напруги електроенергії.
До того ж, попереджають деякі експерти, ціна на електрику для підприємства закладена в ціну товару, який вони виробляють.
Тож ця цифра все одно буде відчутною для сімейного бюджету багатьох українців, але вже в частині покупок.
Зменшувати фінансове навантаження незахищених верств населення уряд планує за допомогою субсидій.
Станом на зараз субсидії, а це цього року приблизно 2 тисячі гривень, вже оформили два з половиною мільйонів домогосподарств.
У бюджеті 2021 року на субсидії закладено 35 млрд гривень.